quentin lafargue c'est l'histoire d'une
mécanique bien rodée le pistard a
commencé le vélo à l'âge de 12 ans dans
une école de cyclisme en gironde
c'était en 2003 sur le vélodrome de
bordeaux comme tous les jeunes j'ai vite
eu quelques résultats et ça m'a surtout
beaucoup plus toutes les épreuves liées
au sprint à la vitesse
j'avais un gabarit assez un corpulent
quand j'étais plus jeune et surtout plus
court plus corpulents que les autres et
du coup je prenais beaucoup de plaisir à
faire des disciplines de sprint
aujourd'hui quentin lafargue à 29 ans il
côtoie un autre vélodrome le national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est ici que le sportif décroche ses
premiers résultats sur la scène
internationale en 2016 l'athlète
remporté l'or sur le km lors des
championnats d'europe en 2015 première
médaille sur un championnat du monde
avec le bronze en vitesse individuelle
c'était vraiment le dernier sprint du
championnat après moi ans ils ont éteint
la lumière presque donc voilà c'est une
vraie enfin une vraie belle image mort
genre tiens énormément d'émotion et
voilà 6000 personnes qui crient pour te
faire pédaler un tout petit peu plus
vite c'est voilà je vous lirai jamais ça
2015 une année particulière mais 2019
restera une année unique pour quentin
lafargue le sportif a remporté cette
année trois titres trois médailles d'or
sur le kilomètre lors des mondiaux les
championnats d'europe et de france
une très belle saison 2010 9 sur
laquelle physiquement j'ai montré que la
progression confins suivait son cours et
est en tout cas qui donne beaucoup de
confiance pour la suite ça faisait
quelques années qui tournait autour ou
un peu autour du cou et je dirais que
cette année elle ait été l'année de la
consécration de de cantat mais ça fait
quand même quelques années qu'on consent
planter un peu faire des grands
résultats
des résultats qui permettent à son
équipe le vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines team vous sert
d'avoir un rayonnement international
quant à la farga rejoint cette structure
en novembre 2018
c'est une fierté c'est une fierté c'est
exceptionnel c'est quelqu'un de humble
humble et porté vers la jeunesse
un exemple quentin lafargue espère
maintenant décrocher son billet pour les
jeux olympiques de tokyo l'année
prochaine
en espérant que 2020 soit une aussi
belle année que 2019